Hello everybody my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Finding Bigfoot
Now, I know I said I was gonna play this game in multiplayer the next time I got around to it
but there's some thing's that I've overlooked
There's actually a map in this game
and no, I'm not talking about this map
I see in front of me
even though it would've been good to look at that while I was playing the last time
but there's a map and a whole slew of other controls
that I didn't even know were here (nice going, Mark)
X is bait
Q is map
V is disguise a trap
That's what I needed to do to be able to disguise
and bait all the traps
instead of just laying the meat
somewhere in the vicinity of the trap and not actually on the trap itself
So supposedly
if I follow these instrutions
I might actually be able to capture Bigfoot
I don't know if that's going to be true, I'm still sick so
we're gonna see if Sickaplier is gonna be able to conquer against Bigfoot
if that even made any god damn sense at all
[Scary growls]
Okay hi...
Hello... You're not Bigfoot
oh it's the break of day
Okay so I still got-- I still got a chance (do you, Mark?)
before Bigfoot is gonna come after me
And also
I found one
of the previous campers from before
but Bigfoot is still out there
And I need to find Bigfoot
before Bigfoot finds me
Alright here we go
Come on Bigfoot, where you at, big boy?
Give me the signal bullets
Give me the tracking bullets
Give me the gun
Where-- This is rope...
I don't need more rope I need a gun
Where did I put the gunbsinahdajdsshjcz
I don't remember where that was
Hello?
Gunbzingshajhcz?
Gunnnn?
No??
Where the- Ah! Here we are
that rifle was right in front of my face
Okay!!
So what I need to do
is I need to use the tracking bullets!
Instead of the stupid bullets that I was using before
that was just trying to damage him
Eventually I'm gonna kill him?
Question mark... I don't know if that's 100% true
Buuuuuut if I'm not stupid
then I should be able to
1: Rip this branch
2:
Bigfooooooot?
Bigfoooooooooooot?!
Bigfoooooooooooooot!!!
Are you there Bigfooooooot?!
Bigfooot!
I should be able to find me a Bigfoot
So
God dammit
These fucking footsteps always mess with me
Just like Bigfoot is messing with me in these woods!
But don't worry, I'm back!
I remember last time how you gave me the run around by
biting my face off
and then I died
on the stupid trap
but that's not gonna happen this time
because I know the controls
maybe
a little bit
my... maybe
I don't know
This seems like a good spot
For a trap
Let's put this bad boy there
"You need to mask it after placing it, use branches to do this"
Okay that was a good move with the night vision there
Okay X to bait V to disguise
So I need to V it
Ahhhhhh!
That's a quality trap!
And then
Where did I find the meat?
The meat was in the fridge!
That's right!
Ughhhhh
Okay
Alright
Hello meat! (hi Mark)
Ohhhhh delicious!
Can I find one of the campers
and take them for extra meat?
That'd be nice
Better be careful, wouldn't any of this to spoil now would I?
No I would not
Okay, so I'm assuming that this is just [fart noise]
Ehhh that's good, okay that's-that's good
Hey, Bigfoooooot!
Dinner's ready Bigfooooot!
Bigfoooooot!
I know you don't like to come out in the day!
But I just wanted to say you look lovely wherever you are!!
I think you're very pretty!
And you know your foot isn't all that big in comparison to the rest of your body!
You shouldn't have insecurity issues when you're actually very attractive!
Not to me...
but to something... one... thing
someone
I don't know... maybe maybe maybe it's a lost cause
I'm just trying to build Bigfoot's self-confidence
One shout at a time
Just like I'm trying to build all of your self-confidence
one screaming, raging, moment at a time
Ohhhh did I mention I'm still sick?
I have the flu
That's a thing I got
So what I'm gonna do
Is Ima look at this one
Even though it's within stepping distance of my, my place there
You what, maybe I'm gonna rethink against that one
But if I-
Loook! [amazed Markimoo]
It's a map!!!!
I gots a map!
Well ain't this just delightful
Ohh and it was a swamp up North!
Ohhh man
Can I call this guy Shrek?
[Murmers] I probably should
Mmmk so what I need to do
rip this branch because I'm angry
and I've got issues that I need to work out
but also
I'm gonna go thisn way
Oh that's so handy!
Oh that's so handy! What's this big bridge or gate type thing?
Oh I can't see where I'm going, I hope I don't run into a Bigfoot!
[Owl hooty hoots]
Is that the hooting hoots of a Bigfoot??
Or is that the hooting hoots of a sasquatch?
I don't know but I think it's gonna be
[Murmers] A fun time
Who the hell is hooty hooting??
Hooty hoo! The cops are coming
Alright so we were reaching some sort of-- Ohhhh
Well ain't that just a big ol' bag of dicks?
It's not a bridge at all it's a gate
"Thanks for visiting Jasper National Park!"
I wanna leave! Help! I'm trapped in here with Bigfoot!
I don't know what to do with my life!
I'm kinda lonely I go out into the woods alone looking for sasquatches and Bigfoots!
I don't really have anybody to hold me at night!
Besides Bigfoot and preferably that's not my ideal scenario!
He holds a little too tightly!
Alright, okay I'm gonna lay a trap down
Oh this is a good one
yup that's good
oh that's real disguised
BOINK
Yeah, that's a good one
Oh this is nice
And I'm gonna put this camera in this perspective because staring at the bridge - errr..
what I call the "bridge"
the gate out of here would be just plain dumb
Uhhhh BOINK
Okay, made a camera
So now I can watch this one to see if the Bigfoot
has been caught
Alright, so that's two traps
Very intelligently placed by the intelligent me
I'm strategerying this
so that when Bigfoot comes out at night
hopefully I'll be able to capture him
her
Ughhhh
I am healthy yes I am
I am healthy look at me!
I've got a lot of health inside my body!
That's how health works yes it does!
What the fuck did I put-- What is that?
What's on my map? Why does that say "1"?
I don't know why that says "1"
That doesn't bode well for me, I don't like the sound of that
Alright well anyway I'm gonna go this way
This looks like a good good good viewing point
I'm gonna put another trap right here
Nahh I'm gonna put it more in the
accessible area
right.... right here
'Cause I think they can swivel, can't they?
Disguise it!
No one'll find it!
[Scary monster roar]
Bigfoot?
B-Bigfoot!!
Sasquaaaaaatch!
Did you get caught by my traaap?
If I go back home am I gonna find you caught in my traaaap?
Or was that just you announcing your presence to me because I don't think I've heard that noise before
Bigfoooot!
Okay I'm just gonna cower in a corner and try to shy away from you
because I don't want my intestines ripped out of my boooody
Aw I forgot to put a camera up there, I was so startled by the Bigfooot
The call of the sasquatch
Well now I gotta go back there and put a camera on it because who knoows? (I know)
Ooo
Did you guys see that?
Oh! That's a deer. That is not a Bigfoot you've got tiny feet!
You get out of here with your tiny feet!
You better damn believe your ass I'm prejudice against tiny feet!
Get the fudge out of here!
With your little dinky danky twinkle toes!
Fuck you!
Sorry
I get really prejudice when I'm sick
[Markiplier shoots his fridge for no apparent reason]
Fuck sorry!
Didn't mean to do that
I'm just so angry, gotta shoot my fridge
[Mumbles inaudibly]
[Sings like a huge man baby]
Looks like there's nobody here
Doodle doodle do boo boo!
Okay. Time to meander back
Uh oh, sun's almost going down
Am I gonna be screwed?
The answer might surprise you!
Oh wait, no it won't!
The answer is yes.
Ooo it's so pretty!
Ahh what a good day to die in the woods by Bigfoot
I can't believe
I'm so stupid
to come out here
on my own
what am I thinking?
Right now?
Probably
how sick I am
That's what I'm thinking
Ah
Here's my trap
Don't step on it
glad they made that real faint
so no one could see it
really good design
BOINK
Boop boop, okay so I got that
I got this
I only got so many tracking bullets, can't waste em shooting fridges
But that fridge popped out at me! It was asking for it.. I don't know
Did I say something else horrible?
Ahhhh those are my camera positions
Okay I see what you're doing you rouge!
I have a funny feeling I'm about to encounter sasquatches
But if I can just tag him with a few tracking bullets I think it'll work out a little better
for me than it did last time
alright so I think I'm gonna put it up in a little clearing over here
I need to rip another branch
NAW I'm good my anger management is being tolerated pretty well these days
Bigfoot ain't gonna get nothing on me
I'm gonna get a whole lot of something on Bigfoot
Namely, my feet on his feet
just to- just to assert my dominence
I like this hill right here oh yeah
oh that's the good stuff oh meat that up
mmm yeah good I love it alright
We'll point this camamamera
Right there
perfect
Okay and as you can see I've got the perfect strategum
The distribution is ideal
No one will be able to escape this
when I've got 10% of the entire map covered
[Birds cawing]
God, I hate that
[Birds ignore Mark and continue to caw at him]
I hate that so much
[Bigfoot snarls]
Ahh! Woah woah woah!
What the fucking-- ahhhhh ahhhh ahhh
It's BIGFOOOOOOOT!!!
I've tagged you!!!
Ah ha! You've been tracked!
I think... I don't know
Have you been tracked? I have no idea
Bigfooooot!!!
Come back I just want to study you!
in pieces [hehehehe]
Come on!
Play a little game here!
It's the game I call:
I'm Gonna Stab You With Bullets And Then You Die
And Then I Wrap You Up In Rope And Drag You Back To Civilization
It's kinda fucked up when I say it like that
I literally am going into this guy's home
I mean
yeah, he killed a bunch of campers, but
they came into his house
if someone comes into your living room and starts camping out, you know
you might be a little concerned about that
just a little bit
Alright so what does that mean
oo
wait a minute
[Gasp]
I've got it
I can see him
I tracked him, good
I hit him with trackers!
Oooo!
I did not need to use that many trackers
okay
[Rumbly sound of night]
Well that's a rumbly sound of night
Okay but this is good
'Cause now I'm not just wandering around aimlessly anymore
[Whispers] I can actually find him
So
Ooo he's coming right for me
So I'm gonna put another trap here
cover that up
let's blast that with some goop
put this right here
oh yeah
Oh he's coming right for me
Wait, maybe he's going for the trap that I set by the trailer
Okay, alright
He's somewhere right over there
Wait did I see him?
Bigfoot?
Bigfoot!?
Bigfoot!!??
Bigfoot! Hit my trap!
Hit my trap!! You didn't hit my god dammed trap!!
Hit my trap!!!!!!!
Ow!
Bigfoot!!
You're a meanie!
You goof!
You goofed me good
I'm gonna goof you with bullets
Alright okay that's how you wanna play Bigfoot?
I gotta heal, or else I'm gonna die
I wouldn't wanna die
[Rumbly night sounds again]
So Bigfoot's going back towards the winter (?)
Ohhh Bigfoot's going back to your swamp?
Awww Bigfoot can't take the pain?
Too bad Bigfoot
Alright so I- I don't even know if I'm gonna have enough bullets to take him out
It depends on how much uh like the traps do in terms of damage
I don't know why he didn't go over the god dammed trap
Ohhh he's coming back for me
Oh boy, okay
Alright, shouldn't take shit, ah
Uhh, alright how about this?
Okay, is he coming right for me?
Oh yeah, oh yeah he's coming right for me
Oh yeah brother
He's coming right for me
Where you at?
Heal, okay I healed
Are you back, Bigfoot?
Huh? Oh, coming straight for me
Oh right down the line!
No, in my trap! In my trap!
He didn't hit my god dammed trap again!!!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
Bigfoot! He hit me!!
Bigfoot, stop that
Bigfoot, you're such a meanie puss
Bigfoot, what are you doing?
Why is Bigfoot so much angrier than he's been before?
I mean, what a dick bag
Bigfoot is really letting me down, here
I had a lot of high hopes about Bigfoot
I hope you find them, Bigfoot
I'm out of meat, I'm out of traps
I'm almost out of bullets
Well not really, I've got bullets
Alright, what do we go here?
Bigfoot's across the bridge
like a big dick
Ugh! Alrighty then
Well what am I supposed to do? I'm just a lonely guy
in the middle of the woods
Okay, where is he? He's close to 3
Okay, he's close to 3
He's around here somewhere
Bigfooot!
Ooo!
It's
Bigfoooooooot!
He's got the biggest feet!!
Where you going!?
Come back you bitch!
God damn you lumbering buffoon!
Fine then, you just go over there
I don't wanna mess with you anyway!
[Markiplier makes gun noises]
Alrighty then, well that does me no good
So he's
Oh noooo
Did I loose, did the tracker wear off?
I shouldn't've shot him with literally all of my tracking bullets
Well that's unfortunate
Okay, so he's somewhere down to the South
And I ran out of trackingness
Maybe he's going for one of my traps
Maybe he'll show up and take it
Oh! He did!
Oh! Have you been? Did you get hit?
Oo
He's at 2
Okay he's at 2 right now
Get out there- ahh
Where's 2?
2 2 2 I'm coming for you 2 2!
Twwwooo!
Habooski!
Oh yeah did I illuminate your your your eatingness?
You better be in that trap
When I get over there you better not be out of that trap
and eating my face
'Cause I won't, I won't tolerate that that that's a big no no
A big no no in my book
Okay it's dark
HADOOSKI!
Please tell me he's in the trap
I bet it's not this easy
Come on where you at? Where you at?
Awwwww! Dammit!
God dammit!
He's really running me for a look now
The douche
Well, okay
[Markimoo sings his little heart out]
I don't know where he went
[Markiplier continues to sing]
I'm lost
Bigfoot?
Habooski!
You out there? You out there big boy?
I've got it!
Okay
So what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna try this again
'Cause I think I know what I need to do to catch the Bigfoot
I'm gonna try this, I think I screwed myself over
I had a- I was on the right path
I just, I Markipliered it and it just went wrong
somewhere
Okay, be a female Markiplier, gotta do that, that's a must
Take that rifle, take this take that take the battery
Take these traps
I've got an idea for this that I think is gonna work
'Cause I only have so much meat, right?
But
I don't need to put all the meat
right on top of each other, you know what I'm saying?
Uh
I don't need to use
all the meat when I'm doing this
I can use some of the meat
and then
put traps around the meat meat
And then hopefully that's gonna allow me to be a bit more
you know, thoughtful about what I'm doing
Okay, and then, what you have here
you have a main trap
and depending on which one he goes for,
he might go for one, he might go for another, who knows
but depending on which one he goes for
you can have
the ability
to maybe not be
terrible and and bad and stupid
like I was before
Hey sun can you hurry up, I need it to be night so that I can get my ass chewed off by a Bigfoot
You know, it's always been my dream to have my ass torn off and mounted on his wall
Bigfoot I mean, not just anybody's wall
I hope when I die that I can have my ass immortalized in a statue in my honor
That'd be my dream
You know for all my lifetime accomplishments and making the world's most amount of dick jokes
and...
simultaneously having them be the worst dick jokes known to man, that's my objective
It's what I aim to do
hope to do
with your support I can get there
[Bigfoot strikes again with his loud ass screams]
Woah! Is that the sound of the Bigfoot being activated?
Ooo me like that
Oo that ran chills down my spine, Bigfoot
Where you at big boy?
Oo! Oo he hit something! What did he hit??
Wait what did you hit? Did you hit my trap over here?
Which one-- Ahhh that one!!
It was that one!
It was it was that one!
I I realize now, it was that one!
I realize the crux of my error, you hit the one over there
I was dumb and just ran right into you
But now I've got a tracker in you
So lemme just reset my traaap over here
Which one did you trigger?
Oo I've got a good-- oh you didn't get the meat did ya?
No no no you did not get the meat!
Ho ho ho ho and now I've got you
So where're you at buddy boo?
Oh, other side of the lake
Oh so sad for you!
'Cause I'm- I can shoot that far
Maybe
It's gonna be a shooting gallery for me
Oh, I see you over there
Oh, I see you
Uhhh, what's this uh KABANG
Oh! Hit ya!
And another one for you
Am I hitting you? I have no idea
How do I know if I- Ooo yeah I think he's charging
Ahh I think he might be charging for me
Aw he doesn't even know he was being shot at
He's so stupid
and lumbering
like a lumbering stupid
Okay, where's he going?
Aw I can't see shit
Oh... where is he?
Okay, right over there somewhere
Somewhere he's over there, I know he's over there
He's over there, I gotta get him
I gotta get him, oh he's over the hill
Okay, oh I almost ran right over my traps
Okay, is he coming for me? Oh he might be
If I can get him over the traps...
Ohh he's going for the other ones!
I gotta hit him with uhh, I gotta hit him with another bullet
another tag
[Growls of Bigfoot mixed with begs of mercy from Mark]
God dammit
How did I goof that? God dammit
God dammit!!!!!
Dammit
How did he sneak up on me like that?
What a load of bullshit, he's so fast!
God dammit! Stop going towards the god damn swamps and face me like a man!!
Or a giant lumbering beast man!
That's also an option
One of the two, I'll take either, it's cool
Oh wait, got him
Okay I think I tagged him
Okay here we go here we go where is he? God dammit!
Fucking trees!
Where is he? There he is
Yeah, yeah get some! Get some! Get rekt!
I'm out of bullets!
Ahh ahh, I've gotten rekt
[Gun shots and "Ah"s from Mark]
Alright yeah you better run away!
Please tell me he's actually running away
okay good
Okay, I'm doing some good damage on him, but he's also doing pretty- pretty good damage on me
Not gonna lie, he's doing good damage on me
[Markiplier being sneak attacked and wasting bullets]
I'm gonna try to tag him before he...
I think I got him, I'm pretty sure that was fresh tags
Okay so what I'm gonna do next, because I can't take another hit
I'm gonna try to...
reconvene back to my uh...
my traps
'Cause I got him at a little more than half health
he's got left so if I can get him back at my traps...
and I can at least keep-keep a close eye on him
then I'm gonna be able to
Ah here he's coming back already
He smells the meat
He knows it's there
He knows he- he can't resist it
Alright so I need to reconvene, try to get some ammo
Oh this is gonna be close, I don't know if I'm gonna be able to do it
There's another med kit back home, so I haven't forgotten about that
But uh this might, this might be uh dicey
Let's just make sure
Okay, he's B-lining for 2
which means he might go right by this window here
But uh what happens if I turn off all my power?
Huh? He'll never even know
Oh he'll, he won't know I'm here
Oh he's not even gonna know
Hey Bigfoot!
Bigfoot!
Bigfoot?
Oh, hi Bigfoot!
You can't get me I'm in my god damned base
WOAH!!
Woaahh!
Well fucking woah!
What!?
This task is too difficult to you!?!
for you
for to you
What!?
What a load of bull shit!
Awww come on!
Okay well anyway I failed
I didn't know he could do that. That's a new thing that I didn't know about
Well then
There you have it so... I need friends
That's just a general statement not about this game
But I need friends also to help me
track down the Bigfoot
If I can beat the Sasquatch, then I can feel good about my life
So, in the next episode I definitely will have friends
to help me along with this
So thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see YOU in the next video
Buh-bye!